hi in this video I would be talking
about the structural details of the TLR
the toll-like receptors so the toll-like
receptor has three particular domain one
domain is extracellular domain another
domain is TIR domain which is stole
interleukin 1 homology domain it occurs
is named because it has a homology with
interleukin 1 receptor and also it has
are transmembrane domain which is
actually embedded in the membrane now if
we talk about the right-hand-side
structure it is a x-ray crystallographic
structure of tlr3 and Taylor 3 does not
work individually it actually homodimer
eyes with each other and then it can
detect viral dsdna so you can also see
here the viral double-stranded DNA is
actually Co crystallized with this
particular tlr3 and now the whole
structure of the tlr3 is not depicted
here only the head region the leucine
which repeats the lrr domain is actually
depicted over here so now we would look
into the details molecular details of
the exterior domain and TIR domain
separately so let's talk about the
exterior domain or the extracellular
domain of the TLR and in our case it's
tlr3 so here we have the PDB file the
protein databank file which is actually
the atomic coordinates for the x-ray
crystallographic structures so if you
open the PDB file for tlr3
we would find something like this and
the here you can see it has quite
similarity with that diagram that I have
shown you earlier we would change the
display a little bit and it's look up
quite similar and now we would see the
structural details how much hair this is
it have how much beta sheets it's have
and we would also see the live scene
which repeats so let's write in the
comment comment prompt select helices
so it would say 1 4 8 2 atoms are
selected so 1 2 1 4 8 2 atoms are in the
hellix so now we would color it with a
different color we would give it a red
color and you can see when I press that
so the helices region are actually
colored with rate now let's see how much
better [ __ ] we'd have let's see we will
type select beta sheets
oh it takes actually select sheets and
it would say 2 8 8 6 atoms are selected
and we would color it green and you can
see the beta pleated sheets are actually
colored green and now we want to see the
portion of the leucine-rich repeats so
we would select lose him and we would
color them in cyan and we would change a
little bit display and now you can see
all the loosing residues are actually
colored so you can see the along these
backbone of this particular question
mark like structure which are actually 2
tlrs dimerize homodimer eyes with each
other you can see there are a lot of
leucine which repeats and if you zoom
into it you can see there are a lot of
loose enriched leucine residues and
there are a lot of them so that is why
it is called the leucine rich repeats
and let's talk about the structure of
the TIR domain so
we would open the structure for and the
TIR domain and if we open the structure
of the tii domain it's a bit more
simplistic and and now we would just
label the henesys and we would color
them and we would call it the helixes
yellow
turns and now you can see this is the
basically structure of the TIR domain
and I have shown you earlier so it has
one billeted sheet and it actually have
five alpha helixes so here one two three
four five and six so it has six alpha
henesys you can see and there are other
these white portions are actually the
turns and this TIR domain is essential
because the toll-like receptor adapter
my d88
my ZT it is stands for my low
differentiation factor it also have this
particular TIR domain so TIR TIR
interaction actually help the in the
signaling pathway which we would see in
details in the sigma TLR signaling so
that's all about the structural details
of TL r and its extracellular and
intracellular domain so if you liked my
video give it a big thumbs up and if you
haven't subscribed subscribe yet please
subscribe and don't forget to leave your
comments below thank you